[Music]
okay now before we then transition
into now think about like this is all
still like english sentences right we've
got to really get this
negative thing so
if you haven't already made this hey
let's do it right let's think about
the negation of each of these and see if
we can unpack the logic and what's going
on
if i say to you what's the negation of
ph
p and q
negation means it's the exact opposite
right so everything that was true now
becomes false
everything that was false now becomes
true yeah
so if you have a look at his is pnq
right okay
the negation of this statement has to
flip
everything here right so this would
become false and then these become true
true
are you with me so how would we
state that i could just list them
couldn't i right there's three things
uh i'm gonna put stars on them one two
three that i want to be true so so i can
just list these out right
i could say uh the first one in the top
right hand corner is
not p and q
is one of them right or it could be
uh not q and p
that's the bottom left hand corner um or
i'm just gonna
not p and not cute
so i've just i've just exhaustively just
dipped them out this would be correct
but boy does it look more great is there
a more succinct way
that i could say i kind of want to
include this entire column
and this entire row does it look
familiar
have we got language even language on
the board that captures
when you want to include everything in
this and everything you can even click
right not p and not q what word do we
use when we
how does this work well not p means as
soon as you say not p
then you say or you're including
everything in this column is that okay
but then saying not q means you're also
including everything in this row
and you're leaving the possibility of
having both does that make sense that
was actually the point that we're just
discussing what is inclusive
so some of you were saying to me before
why does and
turn into or when you want to gain
a statement and here is the answer right
in order to make
the negation of this guy you have to
include everything
all of the possibilities that were false
before we're now saying they're true
that's what a negation is it's the
opposite
so to capture all of them you either
write every single possibility
or you say is there a more succinct way
to capture
those three statements that i think are
true in one statement
not paid not huge just like you saw
before here but in
[Music]
we were having long discussions and um
i'm not going to say arguments like
we're trying to work this out ourselves
we've taught this before
this is a new course um i actually
didn't formally study
any of this when i was in university
started learning alongside you and
kind of enjoying it but it's also quite
tricky right
okay out there i
had never seen truth tables whereas mr
blue hat and we were discussing whether
we would introduce them or not
and i think and can we get a bit of a
gauge
are they helpful to send it out in their
table form
or is it more confusing
[Music]
i think we're getting helpful because
that's what we were trusting that's
where we landed
um it's worth pointing out because these
aren't in the syllabus right if you're
looking at this and like
um i'm not confused this is not helping
right then drop it you know how
sometimes we're like
uh here's two methods even if you like
one more than the other you gotta know
both
just tough sometimes we're gonna say do
it this way even it's the way you don't
sorry hard i want you to do it anyway
right um so sometimes or if it's in the
syllabus
we don't give you an option this one we
hope it helps if it's not
don't worry okay i've got a negation for
the and statement
now i want a negation for the all-state
and maybe
you're a couple steps ahead of me
already i'm looking at this true table
down here let's start let's get rid of
this for a second just
so here is p or q to negate this
i'm going to flip everything everything
that was true before becomes false
everything that's false becomes true
now this is remarkably simple isn't it
because there's only one false thing
that you want to be true
so unlike in this situation where you
have a long awkward list what's the one
you're after
which one do you want it's only one
right
it's say it again
not p and not q they have to both be
true at the same time
not p and
it's not cute it's kind of a nice
symmetry to this do you see
okay um are you thinking or you've got
questions
that's a really great question let me
just repeat it just in case um
um the question was see how you've got
this word and here right
could we replace that and with a
two-sided arrow
with a two-sided arrow i'm gonna throw
to the floor
because i have some thoughts on this i'm
sure mrs lee's uh and our other
colleagues in the room will suggest
importance
is it rude yeah no i'm gonna ask you to
do it okay um i'm gonna give
astrid for a thumbs up or a thumbs up
okay thumbs up
look at it closely and maybe you want to
use the english statements to help you
out here
okay the word and here
is um and you can actually substitute
anywhere can we substitute
the word and for a two-sided arrow
everything about what a two-sided arrow
means have to think about
what and could mean in this context
anyway
yes i think it can be replaced no i
don't think it
can be replaced i think they're
different
hold for a second because i want you all
to come to completion in your own life
and you know how this works when i ask
all of you okay
okay i'm gonna do count to three
okay hands up hands up in the air give
me a fist
all right here we go it's gonna count to
three and i'm gonna ask you a thumbs
down
for a thumbs up okay uh one
two three which way
oh look okay i'm gonna do a count
i've got i've got a favorite majority
yeah okay most of you are saying thumbs
down at the moment okay including the
person who posted the question
all right so the the question
can we do it okay someone who said
no tell me why
you have given us some good thoughts
from today i want to see if anyone else
can throw in if that will come to you
but come on several of you put
your thumb down even if you're like i
don't know it's my instinct bro what do
you reckon
arrows they say that like p implies q
and g implies p
but p and q is a separate statement
because
it's just the same expected it has to be
both of these things you can't because
if you have one of those
with the if you have like not p with the
dual arrows then that just means that
she was true
but if you have an n
[Music]
so yes what you're saying
is there's a difference in the
relationship between p
and q when you say and it sounds like
am i summarizing this correctly sounds
like it's kind of a looser
connection it's like yeah they're just
they're true right
but when you put in those um when you
put in that double arrow
and you can see it from your answers
right
we can actually in terms of english our
most succinct
replacement for the double arrow is if
and
only is right so there's actually now
somehow a logical connection between
this
one leads to the other and the other
leads back to the one
right now there are what you're actually
getting at here
is a really important it wasn't where i
was going to go today but
you went there so i'm running with it
okay um what you're getting at here is a
really
important statistical idea i wonder if
um i wonder if you remember this from
advanced last year
i don't know if you've seen this about
before it's one of my favorites
um what's it telling you
what it's telling you is there's
something eerie going on
whenever nicholas cage uh releases
a film i don't know what the codes are
what's going on well this is this is
just data and it's true
right by the way if you're wondering why
it's so morbid it's because sadly
cause of death is something which we
have very good after all so there's lots
of information on this that's publicly
available
from governments around the world by the
way because of course
right now then you've got this matchup
right what do we call this
it's a fancy word uh start to sing when
two things
seem to happen together one goes up the
other goes up one goes down the other
goes down let's call it correlation this
is called correlation right it's a
really important statistical
idea a lot of the things that you see in
the news about like oh scientists state
that blah blah blah
they're actually talking about something
like this a correlation two things that
seem to be happening at the same time
the important idea you know right is
that correlation doesn't
mean causation right it doesn't mean
that one causes the other i really
desperately hope
i mean some occasions are quite bad to
be fair so maybe they would watch this
you know um but there are reasons there
isn't
like that's the point of laughing at
this right that there is clearly not a
causal link
there is clearly not causal link between
these two things
even if they happened to correlate
with each other does that make sense i
know i'm sort of
laboring this point but it's super
important why that these are true
whether we don't say that we can start
off with the other
rather than just me tell you can this is
that okay
all right now sorry we're kind of um
midway through let me uh
i'll just leave that that's fine uh
we're kind of midway through and i was
just pointing out the symmetry here
right the symmetry that i see is when
you're negating an n statement
you end up with an or statement when you
need to get an or statement you end up
with an
statement it's nice it's in turn and
it's going to have a really important
implication for
make little something for me our
negations of
quantifiers okay
did you have something to leave okay
now i want you to think back to what we
said for quantifiers and introduce some
weird symbols for you
do you remember seeing this
we're like we're running out of symbols
with alphabets quick turn something
upside down
and outside a means for all
values of so i'm just going to give you
an example right now
actually i'm just going to go with
example i think you already have your
look
for all values of n where n is an
integer we could say
that if you double n
you'll get an even number do you
remember that yeah we said this is true
okay what would the negation of this
statement
look like if we were to negate this and
i want you to think about
everything that's on the board right now
okay i know it looks a bit different but
actually it's not so different
how would you say the opposite of this
how would you say
i think this statement is false now of
course we just could put the word
out the front but can we turn into
like some language can you have a think
about how we're unpacking this
what would it mean for this to be false
how could you
we know it's true but if you wanted to
prove it false
how much you go about doing it
hmm
if i can find a 2n
that's odd i only need to find
one one i only need to find one and this
has to be false do you agree
because this is saying every single one
out there off to infinity in both
directions
it's always true i only need to find one
this is important
counter example i haven't introduced
this phrase yet but that means a
normal english phrase a single counter
example
will disprove this right now i actually
have a quantifier
i actually have a symbol that says
exactly this that
i don't know i don't know what it is but
somewhere out there there has to be
something that proves this
not true what's the language that we
introduce what's the other quantifier
not for all
it's there exists
somewhere i don't know what it is but i
think there must
exist some value of n that's
an integer right where 2n
is not even it's odd
does that make sense i mean we know this
is false but statements are either true
or false but not both so if this is true
this must be false
if this is true then this must be false
that's what makes that's what defines a
negation
does that make sense how would we negate
this is the negation of a for all
statement ends up without
there exists a statement how would we do
it
in reverse okay now i'm going to give
you a really fun one here i
um i really like this example because
sorry i seem to be doing this a lot
today but this is just too good to not
show you i discovered this when i was at
uni and i was like
what how is this the case okay i'm going
to give you a
there exists statement and
let's see what you can do there exists
some integer n
such that n
can't be written
as the sum
of four square numbers i know that's
seems unnecessarily long and awkward but
wrong with negative okay
i'm suggesting that there's some number
out there
100 53 4 million
and five whereby if you take that number
you can't write it as something squared
plus
something squared plus something squared
plus something squared okay
now just so you understand what i mean
here let's let's think about an actual
level
uh let's think about number like say 10.
can you write this number it's not
squared
but can you write it as the sum of four
squares it's actually not that hard is
it right
what's the biggest square number you can
fit in
right nine so that's three squared what
do you get left with once you take that
nine out
one yeah that's one but one's actually a
square number isn't it
so then i'm like i'll just add a couple
of zero squares so i've written 10 as
the sum of four squares are okay with
that
let's pick another one uh let's say
27. can you do this one
in four squares or less yeah an easy
strategy is to go for the biggest square
what's the biggest way you can figure
that out point five squared
that leaves you with two so what are you
going to do next
one square one squared and another one
is very square
right let's see if we're going to check
let's try this one
this biggest one you can fit um 11.
and then you're like oh oh what's left
is 10.
i already have 10. so i'm just going to
go like so
actually you can do a lot of them
especially in far fewer than four
okay but i'm suggesting you i claim
i propose that there is some n out there
whereby
n can't be written in this way okay
are they disgusting what would the
negation of this look like
and maybe i've given you enough clues
from the negation of these statements
and the notation of this statement
that you could come up with a negation
for this one what would it mean
if this were false hmm
friend you've given us a good idea
already today i wonder if someone else
he can throw a thought and thank you
though i appreciate that
like we i gave you three maybe you're
now curious and you're like trying to
put some other numbers in right
if this is false what's the alternative
come with it it's like on for all and
it's part of like the
what is it saying real numbers
right so what i'm suggesting is oh wait
i just tried a few
what if i could try all of it what if it
works every
single time that's for all values of n
that are integers
this is the opposite right and can be
written
i'm just going to believe that you guys
can write it do you think that could be
possible
it seems wild right could you do every
single
number just before i address that
thought let me just point out the
parallels here
right if you negate p and q number one
you're switching this conjunction and
then you get
negations right uh same deal here you
change this or into an and then you
application
here you switch this this is kind of a
conjunction right
this quantifier tells you something
about what wants to come
and then you indicate whatever result
you have right and that's what i've done
here i've
swapped this there existed value for a
for all
and then i've said well let's write the
opposite
of that result that makes sense
okay spoilers um
and can always be written as a
foursquare so no matter what value
you choose a really smart guy named
mirage physicist might know him as
famous for something else actually but
this is laura granger's very original
there four square theorem
every single number every single whole
number can be written
so it
we now have enough patients to negate
pretty much anything
that we show with you right um no matter
what
my compound no matter what compound
statement
uh i give you do you have enough pieces
to be able to say okay
think about what it means figure out
what's being quantified here
the opposite must be whatever